the humble onion is big business it's
rich in calcium iron dietary fiber
protein folic acid vitamin C no wonder
it is indispensable in kitchens across
the globe but this season the onion
market is in turmoil especially in India
one of the world's leading onion
producers selling over nine million tons
of the stuff last year but this year the
harvest has been hit by a one-two punch
of drought and an excessive rain
the Indian government banned onion
exports altogether as a result
tightening supply further driving up
prices onion is an ingredient in several
recipes across South Asia and in almost
every dish in India but much of the crop
was destroyed during the monsoon season
onion prices we're ten to fifteen rupees
a kilo now they are fifty rupees a kilo
I can't afford that prices have more
than tripled in just onion crisis is
hitting consumers where it hurts most
everyone here is affected yeah he cared
about but again we have stopped serving
onions to our customers due to high
prices the Indian government solution
has been to place a ban on onion exports
as of last Sunday the vegetable can no
longer be sold to other countries and
some believe the effort to shore up
Indians onion supply will help the
Indian government has done the right
thing by prohibiting the export of
onions this will reduce the price and
help buyers but while the band could
change things in India it is hurting
neighboring Bangladesh the leading
destination for India's onion exports in
2018 the affect of the export
restriction is already showing and liday
she's now have to queue for onions the
country has now started buying the
vegetable from other countries including
China
Ashutosh Panda has looked deeper into
this story and joins me now
Ashutosh onions aren't only big business
they're also a political hot potato in
India why is that
well Jared yes as you heard in that
story it is a staple in Indian kitchens
and and and that makes it really a
politically sensitive vegetable arguably
arguably the most politically sensitive
vegetable in India and there have been
examples where it has actually led to
the fall of Cochran so the one that
comes to my mind was isn't is the case
in 1998 when the Delhi state government
was actually watered out of par when the
onion prices skyrocketed and they have
been other instances one in of course
1980 when Prime Minister Indira Gandhi
was voted back to power when the
coalition government then lost because
of onion prices you just mention it it's
not the first time this happened critics
say it's a vicious cycle in part coming
from misguided government policies what
are these policies well it is indeed a
familiar cycle because see the prices go
up when there is some weather-related
event the government steps in it it goes
and actually puts a restriction on
exports prices stabilize then prices
actually go down when new crop comes in
that's when the farmers get worried they
go and ask the government to support
them and the government then easily
restrictions and exports and then wait
for another bad weather pattern and then
the prices again shoot up and and this
cycle continues the experts say that
this cycle needs to break and that's
when they suggest that the government
perhaps should look at we're building
modern warehouses and control supply
that would be used when you have enough
supply and it is a perishable goods so
you need modern store warehouses and
unfortunately they are not enough and
the other thing that they suggest is for
perhaps looking at value-added goods and
things like dehydrator onions so all
this for all this you need
infrastructure and they can be created
close to where there are onions are
grown processing plants and warehouses
is something that the experts definitely
suggest
it's not only affecting India is it
briefly if you can say absolutely not
it's affecting the entire neighborhood
for now a Bangladesh as you heard in
that story Nepal Sri Lanka
UAE there are many expats there who
really
the Indian onions and they also already
suffering and within hours of that
announcement on Sunday of export ban the
prices across these markets actually
shot up oestrus pandey TW business thank
you very much